[glass pops]
My name's Abdullah.
I am a phone-repair-store owner.
Today, I'll be showing you the repairs
of three different iPhones
in three different conditions.
They all have a similar
issue, a cracked back glass.
The repairs are pretty similar,
but each model has a few different steps.
So, this iPhone XS definitely
has seen better days.
Those chunks missing
on the top and bottom,
those look a little scary.
Water could get in there,
debris could get in
there and damage things,
but thankfully everything's
still working all right.
The first thing we'll
do for this iPhone XS,
we'll put it in the laser machine
and we'll burn off the glue
that holds the glass onto the frame.
IPhones come straight
from the Apple factory
with adhesive that holds the
back glass down to the frame,
and it's my laser machine's
job to vaporize the glue
that's holding down the
glass to that frame.
The laser burns at a
very high temperature,
enough to go through the glass,
completely obliterate the
color standing in its way,
and melts the glue straight off the frame.
So, my laser machine
has a specific schematic
for each iPhone model.
It's designed down to a microscopic level
to avoid any gaps in the frame
and strictly go over the metal.
Once all that adhesive is vaporized,
we'll take it out of the laser machine
and we'll go over to our work bench
and start cracking away this glass.
When breaking off the back glass,
we have to be super careful
not to let the blade
puncture through the phone
and damage an internal component.
I use a series of tools
to remove the back glass.
It depends on the damage.
If an iPhone has big chunks
missing on the back glass
and it has easy access to
get underneath that glass,
I'll just go ahead with a
blade similar to a scalpel,
and I'll go in there and
I'll just pry off that glass.
As you can see, the middle of the phone
still has color in the glass.
Apple started using glass backs
starting with the iPhone 8
because of the wireless charging coil.
That's the first model to have
the wireless charging coil.
The reason why it needs a back glass
is so that there isn't a piece of metal
that's affecting the
electricity going through
and charging the phone.
The schematic in the laser machine
specifically omits the area
over the wireless charging coil.
During the second laser run, right here,
you'll see we're vaporizing
the residual glue
left over after removing the glass.
Once the second laser round is done,
we'll take it back over to our workstation
and we'll brush off the rest of that glue.
[brushing]
I use a metal brush that gets in
and scrubs that adhesive
right off of there.
You have to have a surgeon's precision,
because if you go in and
get those metal brush teeth
into a gap, you could damage a component.
Now that I've removed all the glass,
I can finally start putting the phone
all the way back together.
When I'm re-adhering the
back glass to the frame,
I use industrial-strength glue.
It's called B-7000.
Straight from the Apple factory,
they use cold press glue.
We try not to get too close to the edges.
That way we don't have a lot of seepage.
After the repair is done,
if there's any extra glue,
we'll go ahead and clean it
up with some glue remover.
[glass crackling]
Moving on to the iPhone 8, as you can see,
this one, it's cracked,
but it's definitely not as bad as the XS.
And it just has hairline
cracks all over the place,
but thankfully it's
not missing any chunks,
so it looks like the inside
components should be fine.
So, this back glass comes off
almost exactly like how the iPhone XS did.
The only difference is, with it being
the first iPhone that Apple
used the back glass on,
they actually made the glue a
lot stronger for some reason.
So, this repair, I tend
to go a little bit slower
when I'm breaking off the glass,
and it tends to fling a lot farther
just 'cause it's on there harder.
[glass crackling]
One key difference with the
iPhone 8 back glass restoration
is that we have to be careful
around the flash module.
As you can see there,
there's a big hole to the
right of the camera lens,
and unlike the iPhone XS,
where the flash is embedded
within the camera lens,
this one is actually
placed off to the right,
and it's exposed.
Since the laser machine avoids
the wireless charging coil,
the adhesive that holds the glass above it
is actually still there,
so we have to slow down
and use a heat gun and
loosen up that adhesive.
[heat gun whirring]
Right here we have the iPhone 12 Pro Max.
This gold tends to hide
the cracks a little bit,
but you can see them.
While fixing this 12 Pro Max,
we'll follow the same basic steps
with any back glass repair.
The key differences are the raised glass
in between the camera lenses
and being careful when we're going around
the MagSafe components.
As you can see, the glass
is a little bit thicker
around the camera lenses.
Starting with the iPhone 11,
Apple started producing back glass
with glass that's about twice as thick
around the camera lens.
We do face an issue when we're
going to break that glass.
Since it's thicker, it is
harder to get out of there.
To get it out, we actually
have to fragment it.
And to do that, we have punch tools,
and this is similar to something
that firefighters use
to break a windshield.
Thankfully, this punch tool
is specifically designed
so that it only breaks
it on a surface level
and doesn't create enough pressure
to damage any internal components.
With the iPhone 12 Pro
Max, we face a new issue,
and that's the MagSafe.
There are strips of magnets
that go around the wireless charging coil,
and those can be ripped off
along with the glass when
you're pulling it off,
so you have to be very careful
that we don't rip the wire connected
to those magnetic sections.
[scrubbing]
Although it might seem like
a nightmare of a process,
I find it really fun,
and it's also very fun
to see the before and afters.
And that's one of the main reasons
why I do what I do,
just to see the transformation
of bringing things back to life.